sentidos
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a los observadores de
france 24 comenzamos con un acto
valiente ocurrido en moscú el 13 de
marzo que se hizo viral en las redes
sociales
qué piensan si aquí dice sólo dos
palabras me arrestaran
y
la detención de esta mujer fue grabada
por un medio de comunicación ruso
independiente la escena transcurre en
moscú durante una manifestación contra
la guerra en
ucrania
esta mujer llevaba un cartel con la
frase dos palabras escrita en ruso esta
es una forma disimulada de decir no a la
guerra pero desde a principios de marzo
entró en vigor una nueva ley en rusia
que indica que oponerse a la guerra en
ucrania puede acarrear una condena de 15
años de cárcel el camarógrafo que grabó
a esta mujer nos envió una versión un
poco más larga del vídeo antes de su
valiente acto allí tuvieron una
discusión casi en código que
prácticamente no revela cuál es su
posición política de qué medios son
ustedes somos activa tica como activa
tica
no lo conozco cómo se llama artiba tica
activa tica si son de la posición
estamos a favor de los manifestantes
están a favor de los manifestantes y
claro
que piensa si aquí dice solo dos
palabras me arrestaran
la virtud
y en mi cura quien grabó la escena y nos
cuenta la historia
[Música]
era imposible acercarse al monumento oa
cualquier otro tipo de monumento
todo estaba acordonado e incluso los que
se detenían los que sólo caminaban
eran arrastrados a un camión de la
policía eran arrestados y luego
le advertimos a esta mujer que debía
abandonar la plaza rápidamente sin
embargo decidió expresarse
el camarógrafo también grabó a una
segunda mujer que quería recitar poesía
los ojos
y
las dos manifestantes fueron multadas
recibimos una decisión judicial en
infracción administrativa con una multa
de 20 mil rublos 185 dólares si ellas
hubieran utilizado la palabra guerra su
sanción podría haber sido mucho más
severa la otra mujer finalmente tuvo la
oportunidad de recitar su poesía
desde el comienzo de la guerra 760
sitios web han sido bloqueados en rusia
y unos 30 medios de comunicación como
activa tica ya no son accesibles al
menos 15.000 manifestantes han sido
también detenidos
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa a
ucrania el 24 de febrero las zonas
residenciales de la ciudad de hardcore
han sido fuertemente bombardeadas las
autoridades rusas afirman que sólo
tienen como objetivo las
infraestructuras militares sin embargo
las imágenes de algunos aficionados
analizadas y verificadas por nuestra
redacción muestran que la población
civil está gravemente afectada a
continuación una explicación detallada
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
los vídeos de edificios residenciales
destruidos han inundado los canales de
tele gram en ucrania a veces miro y ni
siquiera puedo saber qué parte de la
ciudad es porque los edificios están
irreconocibles están muy destruidos
maría y ala nacieron en harkov en el
este de ucrania a 35 km de la frontera
con rusia
abandonaron la ciudad a principios de
marzo tras pasar seis días bajo los
bombardeos
desde el 24 de febrero harkov es una de
las ciudades más afectadas
cuando todo empezó las explosiones nos
despertaron de madrugada pasamos seis
días en el sótano escondiendo los de las
explosiones escuchábamos cómo se movían
las paredes
[Música]
cuando empezamos a oír aviones supimos
que era el momento de irnos porque
teníamos que salvar a los niños el
ministro de defensa ruso afirma que el
ejército solo atacó objetivos militares
estratégicos
sin embargo en heart kid las imágenes
aficionadas muestran muchas zonas
residenciales afectadas por los ataques
este vídeo fue publicado en telegram el
26 de febrero
fue grabado en el barrio de saltley acá
en el noreste de jarquín un poco más
tarde otro vídeo fue grabado en el mismo
lugar
se pueden ver dos cuerpos en el suelo
según las autoridades ucranianas dos
personas murieron como resultado de este
ataque
sin embargo estamos en medio de una zona
residencial y la base militar más
cercana que identificamos está a más de
3 km
la ong information resilience ha
analizado cientos de estas imágenes
desde el inicio de los conflictos
se ven edificios residenciales saqueados
escuelas destruidas mercados
bombardeados y restos de cohetes en las
calles del centro de la ciudad
hasta el 22 de marzo
267 vídeos mostraban los daños a las
infraestructuras civiles y 14 mostraban
víctimas
en jarquín los restos de los cohetes
pueden darnos una pista sobre su posible
procedencia pues los cohetes lanzados
por el sistema smerch vuelan casi en
línea recta
podemos entonces estimar su trayectoria
observando la dirección en la que los
misiles se plantan en el suelo
volvamos al cohete en el parque infantil
se tomó otra foto desde otro ángulo
observando la tierra levantada por el
impacto y los trozos desprendidos al
frente se puede deducir que el cohete
venía más o menos en la misma dirección
que el camino pavimentado
en bing maps se puede ver este camino
pavimentado está orientado al noreste
al día siguiente un vídeo mostraba
numerosas pequeñas explosiones en el
estacionamiento consistentes con un
bombardeo de racimo
más adelante se encontró un motor de
cohete 9 m 55
si se traza una línea entre el centro
comercial y el lugar donde se encontró
el motor del cohete se puede trazar su
trayectoria y de nuevo apunta al noreste
de jarquín
el alcance de un cohete 9 m 55 es de 20
a 70 km por lo tanto los lanzamientos
provienen probablemente de esta zona
fronteriza con rusia las tropas rusas se
han concentrado a lo largo de esta
frontera durante varios meses aquí es
también donde estas tropas entraron en
ucrania al comienzo de la ofensiva
militar
un convoy ruso fue grabado en un pueblo
ucraniano cerca de la frontera el 24 de
febrero y el día 27 una imagen de
satélite mostraba un rastro de misiles
si se observa con atención se puede ver
una línea blanca en el cielo la foto fue
tomada en la región rusa de bélgorod y
el disparo del misil se dirigía hacia
ucrania
la corte penal internacional había una
investigación sobre posibles crímenes de
guerra
es un crimen de guerra lanzar un ataque
contra la población civil o contra los
civiles para atacar debe haber una
necesidad militar real pero la necesidad
militar no es suficiente el estado
beligerante debe tener en cuenta los
efectos colaterales del ataque y ver si
son proporcionales al objetivo militar
si el 15 de marzo el conflicto ya había
causado la muerte de al menos 600 36
civiles según la onu según la
organización estas cifras son muy
inferiores a la realidad desde el
comienzo del conflicto más de 3 millones
de personas han huido de ucrania como
mariah y ala
claro que da miedo pensar que nuestros
familiares siguen allá mi abuela que ya
no puede caminar que sobrevivió a la
segunda guerra mundial y que tiene que
escuchar esos bombardeos
da miedo
[Aplausos]
diana todo tiene 19 años como millones
de ucranianos ahora es una refugiada
ella grabó la despedida con su padre que
se quedó en ucrania mientras ella iba a
refugiarse en rumanía sus vídeos fueron
vistos por miles de personas alrededor
del mundo a través de 'tik tok' ya no
tuvo que abandonar la ciudad de mykolaiv
un día después de la invasión rusa
with my friends estaba pasando la noche
en casa de una amiga vivo en un pueblo
cuando rusia comenzó su invasión eran
las 5 de la mañana y su mamá nos llamó y
nos dijo chicas despierta en la guerra
empezó a
estar
cuando llegué a mi casa vi a mi mamá ya
mi hermana empacando las maletas dijeron
que íbamos a algún lado pero no sabíamos
adónde ir
voy a extrañar todo esto tengo todo aquí
tengo mucho miedo
estoy muy asustada para ser honesta no
sabemos a dónde ir y qué hacer
salimos de nuestra casa a las 2 30 de la
tarde y en pocas horas los rusos
invadieron mi ciudad empezaron a
bombardear por todas partes
y
manejamos durante 14 horas y luego
tuvimos que caminar hasta la frontera
durante otra hora porque había mucho
tráfico
[Música]
estaba cruzando la frontera y
despidiendo me de mi papá con la idea de
que nunca volvería a casa y que no
volvería a verlo por eso decidí grabar
lo que era nuestro último momento muchos
de los voluntarios fueron realmente
amables y nos dieron muchas cosas porque
cruzaban por la frontera y me hizo
llorar un poquito porque no esperaba eso
todo ese apoyo
creo que tito que es una gran
herramienta para mostrarle a la gente
todo lo que quieres mostrar para
concienciar sobre lo que es importante
especialmente ahora
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es todo por esta semana de los
observadores de france 24 si quieren
comunicarse con la producción del
programa nuestros datos de contacto
aparecen en sus pantallas queremos
agradecer a cabe espacio para la cultura
de la ciudad de bogotá en colombia por
haber sido nuestra vocación el día de
hoy nosotros nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta entonces